bonsoir quand vous avez à l'émission
parce que vous êtes maintenant entrer en
religion chez Investissement Québec
qu'est-ce que vous faites exactement
mais c'est une bonne question puis ça
fait à peu près 6 mois que je suis là
j'ai beaucoup de choses à apprendre
j'apprends encore mais en gros je suis
là pour faire deux choses principalement
d'abord monter toute une oeuvre de
service main-d'oeuvre pour
investissement Québec qui veut en faire
plus pour aider les entreprises qui ont
des enjeux de main d'oeuvre donc il y a
beaucoup d'entreprises et bâtir aussi
toute une équipe d'intelligence
économique donc pour avoir des
réflexions stratégiques sur les grands
défis du Québec puis encore une fois
aussi aider toute la société
l'organisation avec ses réflexions là
donc autrement dit vous allez appliquer
chez Investissement Québec ce que vous
avez constaté dans le fond dans votre
travail d'économiste à l'Institut du
Québec auparavant mais c'est exactement
ça c'est pour ça que j'aime tellement ça
c'est que ça fait des années qu'on lit
des rapports qu'on fait des constats
qu'on produit des données sur nos défis
en termes de main d'oeuvre puis de
productivité et là j'ai le privilège de
pouvoir avec une immense équipe de 13
personne voir comment ça se passe
vraiment concrètement sur le terrain que
les entreprises puis essayer de faire
des changements pour les aider les
accompagner en tout cas il y a tout un
défi quand on regarde un premier
graphique que vous nous avez apporté sur
le vieillissement de la population on
voit clairement que la croissance des
personnes de 20 à 29 ans
stagne en fait il n'y a pratiquement
plus de croissance et que la croissance
des 55-74 ans rejoint la ligne des 20-29
ans ça nous dit quoi du profil
démographique du Québec mais en fait ce
graphique là est vraiment important
parce que ce qu'on voit c'est que une
augmentation rapide des baby-boomers
donc la courte des 55 à 64 ans qui
quittent le marché du travail pour vous
donner un ordre de grandeur de ces 100
000 personnes à peu près qui quittent le
marché du travail en ce moment année
après année 100000 par année 100000 par
année qui prennent la retraite et pour
les remplacer donc les 20 à 29 ans il y
en a à peu près 80 000 qui peuvent
rentrer sur le marché du travail mais
là-dessus il y en a qui étudie qui
voyage qui font d'autres choses et donc
c'est moins de 50% des jeunes environ
50% des jeunes qui vont pouvoir
remplacer ces départs à la retraite là
et donc un gros manque à combler par
l'immigration notamment par une
amélioration du taux d'activité etc mais
aussi par va falloir être plus créatif
sur les façons de penser les besoins de
main d'oeuvre qu'est-ce que vous voulez
dire par là ça veut dire que il va
falloir être plus productif donc avec un
même bassin de travailleur parce que
notre taux d'emploi est rendu élevé le
donc il y a plus tellement de groupes
oui encore des gains à faire sur les
migrants par exemple les clientèle plus
éloignées du marché du travail des
travailleurs expérimentés mais il faut
être beaucoup plus drastique que ça dans
les façons de faire puis repenser est-ce
qu'on peut faire des choses autrement
être plus productifs automatiser ce
numériser on n'est pas à l'avance au
Québec dans tout ce qui est productivité
on est en retard sur l'Ontario notamment
on est nettement en retard sur l'Ontario
puis ça vaut la peine de regarder ces
données là parce que comme on a vu dans
le graphique l'enjeu démographique il
finit pas maintenant on en a encore pour
au moins une ou deux décennies à avoir
moins de personnes qui rentrent sur le
marché du travail que personne qui
sortent il faut se poser la question
comment on peut faire différemment
comment on peut être plus productif puis
on le sait qu'on a de la marge de
manœuvre parce qu'on est très loin de
l'Ontario encore malgré les gains des
dernières années il y a encore un fossé
en qui nous sépare de l'Ontario du
Canada aussi regardons l'exemple de 2021
quand on regarde l'écart de richesse
entre l'Ontario et le Québec pour
différents
items par exemple sur la productivité du
travail dont vous parlez
l'Ontario par personne et
7457 dollars plus riches c'est exact
sur le plan démographique 5400 parce que
plus d'immigrants il y a plus il y a une
démographie qui croit plus rapidement
c'est exact aussi parfait l'intensité du
travail 1300$ et là où c'est à la faveur
du Québec c'est notre taux d'emploi qui
est plus élevé qu'en Ontario
7709$ donc vous voyez qu'il y a plus
d'éléments favorables à l'Ontario
présentement et vous vous dites que là
où on peut faire des gains sur la
productivité du travail mais le profil
démographique c'est difficile de faire
quelque chose à part d’accroître
massivement l'immigration ce que ne
choisit pas le Québec tout à fait même
si on doublait disons le nombre
d'immigrants ça vient pas changer tant
que seul profil démographique du Québec
ensuite l'intensité du travail c'est à
peu près le nombre d'heures qu'on
travaille je pense pas qu'on va aller à
un travail en plus les tendances du 4
jours semaine puis pas des heures
bonifiées en termes de taux d'emplois il
y avait des gains possibles à faire mais
on a maintenant dépassé depuis quelques
années il y a un changement on est
beaucoup plus présent sur le marché du
travail à cause de notre démographie
notamment au Québec et donc maintenant
devant ce notariés au cernes faveur le
taux d'emploi des 15 à 64 ans la seule
place donc où il reste vraiment des
gains c'est vraiment la productivité
puis productivité ou sens large et
comment donc comment on fait pour que
demain la productivité augmente dans les
entreprises puis que on ne fasse pas
quand parler mais que ça marche pour
dans le réel des entreprises c'est de
l'accompagnement puis du financement
c'est faux une économie constituée de
PME d'entreprises avec moins de 100
employés des fois avec des très petites
entreprises qui ont pas de personnes aux
ressources humaines peu de personnes qui
peuvent vraiment se poser ces questions
là même pas de plan stratégique des fois
mais c'est fondamental de les
accompagner puis d'essayer d'identifier
les ondes où est-ce qu'ils peuvent
automatiser ce robotiser avoir des des
logiciels l'intelligence artificielle ça
pour optimiser ce qui se fait et surtout
former les travailleurs puis travailler
fort pour retenir les personnes qui sont
qui partent à la retraite pour que
transfert toute leur connaissance à ceux
qui arrivent là parce que c'est ça le
défi qu'on va frapper un mur et est-ce
que la productivité est un problème dans
beaucoup d'industrie en ce moment au
Québec mais en fait si on se compare à
l'Ontario disons pour prendre un point
de comparaison ben c'est presque
généralisé toutes les industries il y a
un ou deux secteurs où est-ce que c'est
pas le cas mais oui c'est l'ensemble des
secteurs puis si on regarde aussi la
composition industrielle il y a à peu
près le tiers les corps de productivité
avec l'Ontario qui vient vraiment de la
répartition le comment notre économie
est faite mais le 2/3 ça s'applique à
tous les secteurs que ce soit le
manufacturier ou les services très
intéressant mais aussi merci beaucoup
vous êtes toujours la bienvenue on
espère que vous allez revenir plus
souvent nous voir ça me ferait plaisir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]